moscou le vaisseau cosmique robe de
lancer hier en union soviétique avec
deux cosmonautes à bord a atterri le
laissant à toucher la terre en se
servant du système de pilotage à la main
à 12h02 heure de moscou
10h02 heure de paris dans la région de
la ville de perm dans l'oural
les deux cosmonautes le commandant par
des rebelles hayek et le pilote en 2d à
l'excellent est alors se sentent bien
le programme de recherche est
entièrement rempli c'était aujourd'hui à
14h50 le communiqué lancé par la radio
et la télévision de moscou et peu après
de nouvelles images du vol
apparaissaient sur les écrans avec
d'abord les félicitations de monsieur
brejnev aux deux cosmonautes et les
remerciements du colonel bélières
le vol est maintenant terminée reçoivent
2 a couvert plus de sept millions deux
cent mille kilomètres et a accompli plus
de 10 cette révolution
maintenant c'est les résultats qui
comptent sur ces nouvelles images que
nous venons de recevoir de moscou sur de
nouvelles images de la sortie du colonel
léonov dans l'espace nous avons eu
également des précisions par exemple sur
son scaphandre le scaphandre d'alexis
léonov et tisser d'un matériau spécial
protégeant des rayons ultraviolets et
des températures extrêmes
la température à l'intérieur du
scaphandre était de 25 degrés
le scaphandre a en outre assuré une
défense suffisante contre les rayons
cosmiques qui pour un séjour aussi bref
sont considérés comme négligeables dans
les images reçues de la sortie d' alexis
léonov font la remarque et la lenteur de
ses gestes
c'est que même muni d'une mare alexis
léonov avaient reçu des consignes
impératives pour amorcer de la façon la
plus prudente et la plus douce possible
son opérations d'éloignement de la paroi
du vaisseau
la lenteur de ses gestes n'était pas
uniquement due à l'état d'apesanteur
mais aussi à une retenue physique
volontaire
il va maintenant revenir vers son
vaisseau et vous allez voir des images
que vous n'avez pas encore vu jusqu'à
présent et qui sont exceptionnels ce
sont les fameuses cabriole qu alexis
léonov à exécuter dans l'espace regardez
le bien
pour le moment il a la tête en bas
seuls ses pieds apparaissent au dessus
du bos rhodes et il se retourne
voici les premiers pas dans les étoiles
d'un homme